(indistinct chatter)
MAN (over radio):
They refuse to recognize
the existence of the Rohingya.
REPORTER (over radio):
They are in hatred of Muslims.
REPORTER 2 (over radio):
The Rohingya villages have
burned in recent weeks.
REPORTER 3 (over radio):
What can only be described
as a premeditated massacre.
REPORTER 4 (over radio):
The UN says it looks
like a textbook example
of ethnic cleansing.
(screams)
REPORTER 5 (over radio):
Urged to flee for their lives.
REPORTER 6 (over TV):
The world's fastest growing
humanitarian crisis.
REPORTER 7 (over radio):
Over half a million
Rohingya Muslims have now
fled across
the border into Bangladesh.
REPORTER 8 (over TV):
The new arrivals could end up
in the biggest
refugee camp on earth.
KAMAL: Dokana?
JABER: Jaber Hussain.
♪ ♪
Captioned by Cotter
Captioning Services.